guess who's hosting explorer Jeff  Goldblum Jeff Goldblum  I'm Jeff Goldblum thank you for this all  that could have gone a lot worse to then  thank you for this Wow this is Explorer  the intergalactic dating site that we  call space I'm hot hyper active now  because of you you've made me  hyperactive go away go away no look at  those bull keys this is a very yet ish  interview let's move on to a subject  that needs no segue cannabis mmm that's  a lot of valuable information that all  the potheads out there yes I'm looking  to do I can immediately forget come on  at this point you can you can call me a  drunk Jeff Goldblum we could be brothers  or something like that laughing Jeff  Goldblum ha ha and a dead Jeff Goldblum  all this and more right here on Explorer  [Music]  you